欢迎收看赵华
我是赵华
我是艾伦
我们可以想一下
这个礼拜有什么
下个礼拜有什么
下礼拜有放假
那这个礼拜有什么
这礼拜要愿意决策
好
这个礼拜其实有蛮多压力的关卡
可是下个礼拜
有蛮多开心的事情
是的
除了放假 除了中秋节
下礼拜还有台积电的技术论坛
原来是讲这个
而且这礼拜的变音过了之后
下礼拜我们不就是展开个新局的感觉吗
就放完假回来展开新局
加油
当然很多人也会讨论说
要不要看是不是中秋节后
会有所谓的光辉十月
但也许像今天的盘面
就隐隐透露出大家快要受不了了
有点弱动凑强
是
对啊 成家人原本4000多亿嘛
突然放了1000多亿出来
因为今天早上一开盘跟昨天一样
要平盘附近震荡
但昨天是尾盘拉肚子
就感受很烂
就今天是盘中就上去了
没错 其实今天尾盘要拉一点肚子
小小的
所以今天是不是有很多中小辛苦觉得
我不管你晚上怎样
我就是要涨呢
那这样的态势该怎么看
是不是真的不害怕
还有下个礼拜
我们也讲了中秋节的廉价
大家又可以放松一下了
还有台育店的技术论坛
一定会讲很多细光子的好消息
是的
所以我们今天就来帮大家解读一下
这个升息到底是怎么样
我们先来看一下
就是先不讲升息
这个殖利率跟油价都已经先上去了
这些就是跟升息相关的
感觉上现在你殖利率再高
油价再高
怎样我就是升息
对
而且我们现在死猪不怕开水烫
没错就来一起烂
變成這樣是不是
對 因為川普也說
100%支持聯準會
他們自己的決定
所以對 他是這樣講的
以前如果是那個誰
那個鮑娥
是 對
就是說什麼爛主席這樣
叫你下台這樣
現在這個人自己推起來了
就是100%支持
那不過呢 我們先看一下
不只是30年期
我們10年期
昨天還講說
這個有創一個新稿
這一次一樣
昨天晚上繼續
衝到了2007年以來的新稿
也就是說
目前看起來整個殖利率
應該都還是非常在反映
就是目前不太樂觀的狀態
譬如說偷膨的問題
沒錯 然後另外一個則是
不只是單純的殖利率問題
目前油價也遇到了一些問題
所以許多不下
對 有被預期恐過大規模停擺六週
那這個是以供給面來的關係
然後就帶動了不然它原油
還有這個習德州原油
持續的維持在高檔
那这个对于整个科技国来讲
它就会是一个压力
因为对于这种高本益比来讲
都会是比较不舒服的状态
这也是为什么昨天
其实美国股市还是相对偏弱
对 好 那
嘿 嘿
没有 我只是想到说
像那时候关税前
我们也知道有关税的事情
所以股市确实也在压力过中
可是没有想到
关税真的把大家吓坏
所以我刚刚只是突然想到说
虽然感觉上
我们现在叫死猪不怕开水烫
但会不会真的很烫
可能还是会熟啦
所以我们后期要持续注意一下
不只是利率决策
当然我们现在短线观察
重点就是利率决策
但其实后面还是要面临的
就是石油价格持续的往
100前高去做卖进
这个整个还是比较辛苦一点点
那我们就先看今晚的状态
会是怎么样
那当然讲完之后
我们还是要跟大家讲
其实我们台湾目前看起来
还是相对产业非常强劲的
对啊我们又继续有单位
国发会
把我们的GDP成长率再往上靠拢
原本11耶
现在来到12了
是的 好
那目前来说当然了
这个看得出来
6、7、8月
这个是各个地方的公布的成长率
那目前看起来呢
11不是是最高的
主计总处说11嘛
对 然后国发会有喊到12
对 那不过呢通膨
它也是相对还比较高一点
我们台湾央行可能好像也要升息
是 可能可能
礼拜五
就应该知道了
不行吧
现在大家房贷族
还有那些职押股票的
好辛苦啊
对
OK这个也是我们要注意一下
我们台湾确实也有
轻微通膨的问题
好那再来看到了就是
这个台积电OIP论坛
9月23
在美国矽谷要登场了
那里面观察了几个重点
有先进制程类
先进封装类
还有矽光子
没错
所以这一些题材
我觉得像今天的矽光子
有重新发酵的意思
有
对那先进的这个封装
其实一直都还不错啦
那先进制程
我们就看一下后面的
其实创意已经在创新高了
对 所以后面再看一下
有没有机会继续去点高
对 那这个我觉得是一个
对于半导体来讲
或者说对于台湾硬体供应链来讲
的一个信心
对 现在有利空嘛
利空准备要出境了
所以要有利多
那利多要来看
有没有机会让整个成交量
也一起放大
是
然后另外一个呢
就是META有扩大自然晶片的布局
台积电9月呢已经交货了
对 所以目前看起来
都应该是陆续还是有一些乐观的新闻出来
对 所以我们就观察一下
这个联准会讲完
有没有办法放量
然后放量要向上放量
那这行情就会起来了
好 行情起来的话
我想主要的族群都很清楚
半导体的先进封装 先进制程
西光子 自研晶片
其实都是围绕在台湾最强项
就是所谓的半导体上面
是的 所以我们希望半导体要撑住
因为最近的那个
Enthrope这件事情
确实还是可能有些因应的
好 Anthropic 不过大哥是仁薰
他有投 Anthropic 他有投OpenAI
我都给你们钱了
不要在那边吱吱叫嘛
所以他有说
我们不需要安全监管法规
我们会在安全的前提下创新的
没错 然后同时有证实
已经美国在太空部署武器了
不是 怎么现在战场跑到太空
它可以从上面射下来
我还以为是怎么样跟外星人打吗
所以应该会输吧
其实就越来越像电影情节
你看我们的Enthropey就是
类似那个也是电影的情节
然后这个打外星人也是电影的情节
駭客任务
对
所以目前看起来其实
如果是以一个局外人的角度来看
其实我觉得蛮酷的
局外人
对
就是蛮酷的嘛
你看真的电影的事情是在发生的
以单纯一个人类的角度来讲
AI大脑要来了
是的
但是如果我们以这种
可能我们是比较有在观察这些东西来讲
其实听起来蛮恐怖的
是啦 连太空可能都部署武器针对这里
一下人类要被统治
一下可能随时都会有人对你射飞弹
然后听起来就比较恐怖一点
那太空武器当然还是有概念股的
包含了就是台积电 声达科 文帽 莱德光
还有华通 雅光跟耀灯
基本上今天是有反应的
今天蛮强的
今天有反应 开玩笑
像这个之前都是
那一阵子低微卫星红红的时候
这个没有的一个上涨的
强势的个股
莱德光电跟耀灯啊
嗯 没错
好 这个是大家可以去
把它列入自选的
如果对提供微信有兴趣的
可以往这方向去做观察
那再来我们看到就是台湾股市
台湾股市呢
我们直接先看量
量能呢
这几天都是呈现一个
明确的萎缩状态
所以萎缩在干嘛
萎缩就要等放量嘛
放量才有方向
因为无量就无价
那我们之前说过
10日均跟20日均
全部都跌破
那我们后续观察的重点就是
本周一的低点
至少到今天都有做防守
可是防守过程
我们今天盘中涨500点
可是尾盘只有300点
因为又碰到五日均线
就稍微有一些压力了
那不过都还可以接受
只要前低没有破
事件性的一个不确定性结束
行情如果能够垫高
站为全部均线
这边应该就迎来一个
短线反弹的契机
那如果多方要重启
这个前高就要做突破
同时这个高点做突破
基本上就是挑战历史新高
因为趁几百点
对 所以大盘我们看一下
明天跟后天
能不能来一个比较激情的表现
那贵买就比较单纯
它就是区间震荡
即便今天它的涨势是比较强的
而且它没有杀尾盘
然后它涨了2.7%
也比上市来得多
所以今天体感其实很舒服的
因为上柜很强嘛
对
那可是呢
大家还是记得
就也不用太兴奋啦
因为就区间整理啦
所以我们后面
当然这边一定还有空间
那上去的时候这种高点
就要收盘价做突破
这个地方只要做突破
这边就是一个新的行情的产生
那成交量呢
如果能够放大到2000亿以上
会更漂亮
所以上市要守前低
上柜在区间整理
都等一个前高的突破
去做一个新形态的产生
那就是要等事件性了
等明天大家200万放出来
没错
那因为那个捍测结束了嘛
我听说吸了几千亿
8600亿
是的
这个是一天台湾府市的成交量
我今天都听到的都是背报
背包没有抽到
还是要上班
抽到也不用上
会去抽的都已经是有钱人了吧
平白物顾225万放在那里
没错
那我们来看一下联电
联电怎么了
联电很棒
联电这一波
联电很棒是不是
你看这一波是盘整
盘整拉上去之后
这个是涨停板
可以发现我们刚刚台湾股市
是这样向下弯
联电是守住了一个平台
所以目前来说
联电最近的形态
其实都相对比较强劲一点点
蓄势再发
对 跌的时候也跌比较少
那涨的时候它也是有份
那量价呢 这边比较可惜
这四天都是萎缩的
所以一样等一个突破
那突破之后是基本上就是
先补缺口再看前高
好 对 这个是连电
平台突破
再来是看到我们的月光
大平台
没错 慢慢的大平台
就是长这样 结束了
没有啦 开玩笑
就是这个高点还是要
其实这边已经有做突破
但后面行情整个不好
又被整个带下来
它这里创反弹高
那隔天直接跌6%很过分
所以日月光的股性
目前真的是比较不舒服一点点
但是我们等一下来宾会提到
相关的一些题材面
大风策时代要来了
是的 所以日月光
成长要加速了
没错 如果短线上来讲
这边就可能要有一些耐心
等形态上的好转
对 但是它这边就很抗跌
因为虽然抗涨
但也相对抗跌
那就看后续行情能不能
做一个明确的多方债起
然后再去创高
然后再去挑战四位数
是 要对风策有信心
因为资本支柱都在今年
做一些摊提折旧了
明年就是要等营收灌进来
是 所以如果对于长线
有点耐心的
热热光是可以看的
那再来我们刚提到了
就是FOMC会议纪要
原来你是华先生
没有 我是分析华先生的
因为你竟然
这个大家可以
赶快加一下艾伦说的light
他会这个凌晨不睡觉
看华许讲什么
帮大家来解读
到底FOMC会议
这个东西有好几个事情要拆解
不是叫做9月升息就事情结束了
到底未来10月12月明年年中之前
会不会持续升息
它跟台股的盘面
真的叫息息相关
是关注通膨还是关注AI的发展
这个也跟后世息息相关
所以这份报告还蛮重要的
希望艾伦认真写
那大家就用力加起来
等着他明天发送这份报告
那广告回来刚刚特别提到
下禮拜值得期待
特意店的技術論壇
要講的事情絕對就是CPU
好 來吧
光通訊吸引黃金時代
1.6T 解放起飛
今天真的是光通訊蠻熱的
也有很多人講說
發現自己焊測沒抽到
就趕快回來買一下雍智
買下CPU啊
因為是同一個族群這樣
好 那確實啦
今天的CPU相關的
或者檢測相關的其實真的還滿強勢的對 那我們就來看一下最近依舊有一些新的題材在做一個延燒像高盛有大升800G跟光模組的需求
2027年會上修39%出貨
對 所以目前看起來
不只是需求很大
甚至是出貨也開始順利了
而且現在大家都酷
2027就明年
是的 其實就是在看明年了
因為也要準備Q4了
那我覺得這個都是好事
800G目前來說
是大型資料中心的主流規格
那1.6T会开始放量
3.2T则是2027年会开始采用
所以这个光传输的速度
越来越大管
然后这个速度越来越快
我觉得这个都是正向的发展
另外一个则是中国这边的
它有一个光博会
1.6T已经成为主流了
从光引擎 光晶片
还有解调器跟光纤材料
测试设备都已经迎来一个
新产品的迭代
所以目前来说整个有几个特色
第一个800G依旧是主力
那1.6T准备要量产
3.2T跟6.4T
跟以NPO还有CPO的样机验证为主
这里是主力
这是明年的主力
这个是未来的主力
好 而且有讲到一个NPO
它就比较有机会在2027年放量
而且大家有在讨论
美中虽然在科技战
但似乎并没有要去阻止中国的CPO
是喔 看起来是这样
都在讲晶片
可是却没有去讲CPO这一块
可见的需求应该是非常大
对 而且它可能
它也只是传输用
它不是头脑
它可能现头脑
但是中間的這些材料
或者是過程
就不會這麼大的限制
好 這個是CPU
近期相關的一些利多
那我們就來看一下
台灣股市的相關
光通訊的個股
好 都回檔過了
今天符合形態轉好嗎
有一些些有
有一些些還比較可惜
像聯亞就很可惜
聯亞盤中快漲停板
它3,600跌到2,600
跌1,000多塊
對啊 一下就跌1,000多塊
是 很莫名其妙
可是這一波反彈起來
其实它目前还是一个整理的形态
今天啦 因为尤其又很可惜
它原本涨停啊 后面只剩4.8%
对 那其他的像是光盛
我觉得这个都还差一点点
光盛啊 然后还有谁
波若薇也还差一点点
那华星矿也前一阵子跌太重了
它出关跌太重了
就有点落差
剩下我觉得形态都还可以了
这个环宇KY还差一点点
对 其他我觉得都还不错
我们等一下会一个一个慢慢待
而且光镜头又回来了
是的 这连一光真的是很猛
连一光好扯
對 一直往右上角走
台股好像他家開的一樣
對啊 有道理
林立光很誇張
明明就是第三名
大立光跌得那麼重
玉京光難得來一個反彈
但是他已經創高再創高了
所以我們今天稍微來看一下
對 跟大家講一下
目前整個年增來講
前幾名都還是非常大的年增
所以目前他們基本面
是有在逐步轉好的
好 那我們來看一下
裡面其中幾位
第一位就是全新
他其實滿高姿態
是的
那為什麼要講他呢
因為他高姿態
還是一個很像的震盪
也就是他以盤代碟
你看像我們剛剛講
可能零化音
大概主要二到三家
就全新跟聯亞
穩帽甚至還近期討論度
比較低一點
可是這兩家都零化音
但我們剛剛說
那個全新是
聯亞是這樣
就這邊是跌了一千塊
全新他是在區間震盪
為什麼我們不學回黨過的
这么高档你不会怕吗
可是我的想法是它以盘待跌
对对对就是不肯下车
那不肯下车就是等均线跟上
等新的一波动能进来
所以我觉得全新在这个位置上
你看这边是碰月线新高
所以月线要来了
那停顺点也很好抓
就是这个大量这边
这个低点跟这个低点
如果没有做跌破
其实我觉得就可以
让它在这边横盘震荡
等一个新高
那如果需要节省一些时间的
有创高再来追就好了
所以全新我觉得现在形态很强
虽然是创新高在高涨震荡
好 再来另外一个呢
就是潜顶
潜顶算厉害的了
是的
这一波潜顶算猛的
潜顶呢也是有说
有接到辉达的那个订单
我以前记得潜顶都是那种50块而已
那个时候跟比价就是潜顶跟重达
对 然后现在已经是250了
对 他这一波
好 这个潜顶我们这个价格修正一下
265耶
没错
50块变265了
是的
从这边算就好
好
就印象里面是百元以下的股票
没错 前景这一波
其实这波反弹的趋势
其实是算强劲的
甚至比华信光那些都来得强
对 那目前来讲
我们近期可以发现
它股价在这边做一个横盘的震荡
所以我觉得这里只要大量高点
去跟着做突破
这应该前高做突破之后
就是再往前面高点去做买进
所以前景来讲
我觉得这一波
其实形态上也都相对是健康的
我们就找那种相对比较健康的形态
那再来看到另外一个
就是这个仲达KY
位阶相对就好像比较低
今天低位阶的其实还蛮多
就拉一个涨停版
对 其实有很多
关羽KY
对
然后其实还有其他都有涨停版
什么瑞生光
瑞生光电有吗
它不是CPU
不好意思
不是这个光电
东点光电
好的好的 OK
我们来看一下仲达
其实最近也在抽签
今天是最后一天
对 那抽签的过程中
今天最后一天就有放量区做进攻了
那仲达我觉得这个形态我也蛮喜欢的
虽然它曾经跌破了上升趋势线
这边跌破掉
可是呢今天是站上了下降趋势线
然后一口气站回全部均线
然后今天又出一个量
所以在这个状态之下
我觉得至少这里的低点
应该短期内都不会再跌破
那大家就可以去关注一下
如果我进场停顺点抓这里
那看能不能启动一波创高的新行情
好 它是现真
现增的话通常缴完款之后
就看看是不是之后不被这个扰乱了
现在只要募资的都会有点压力
是的 所以已经尾声了
那尾声就看有没有机会来做一个发动
那另外整个营收也还不错
年增100%
单月的营收有跳升了
所以应该是反映整个高速光通讯的产品
有拉货的
这个是后续大家可以好好去注意一下的
一个低位接转强
再来另外一个就是我们的友达
超级便宜
嗯 最大
二十几块
是
对 因为他之前是长输群创嘛
对
但这一波他的形态是不是比群创还要强
是的 因为前一阵子
可能上半年在长群创的时候
讲的题材只有群创有
群创就是有CPU
然后也有跟台积电的合作
对 然后又卖厂嘛
对 那下半年呢
友达也在做一样的事情
友达又有厂可以卖啊
是的 这个
对 他最近也在做他的资产的减肥
都是整个的状态都在规模变小
因为股价这样可能比较拉
比较明确一点
那相关的整个在半导体展
有秀出了整合RDL封装
光学偶合的技术
里面有相关的CPU
就是低功耗而且可以量产的
目前来说其实就也切入
台积电相关的供应链
当然有待证实
但坊间已经把他们撮合了
是的 所以继群创之后
反而因为友达这一波
它前面涨比较少
那这里反而是
它股性比较活泼一点点
当然今天群创也不错
涨了4%
不过形态上就有些落差
因为群创可能连季线都还没站上
那我们来看一下
友达前一阵子是来到了盘中的新高
然后也是前一波的高点
所以这边是套牢区
那套牢区就拉了一个上引线
那上引线之后
刚好伴随大盘
行情比较正当一点
它就一度回测到了
我觉得上来不错的位置
就是原本是压力区
这是大量嘛
原本是压力区
然后呢
站上之后
转为支撑区的地方
所以在今天有拉起来
我觉得都还算健康
那当然五日均线没有站上
我觉得有点可惜
所以在这边的行情
都还是一个N字型
那接下来
这个是新的N字型
所以只要再做一个带量供给
这边行情应该就是
要准备去创新高
或者是说先挑战前高
再挑战创新高
这个目前我觉得都值得期待
然后筹码目前有去看了一下
其实是比群创
稍微来得健康一点点
对
所以我觉得这边有主力在这边蹲
大家可以不妨去多关注一下
有没有机会再拉一个新的形态
好 而且友达的空单
我记得是不少的
是
可能也有酝酿看会不会有点嘎空
其实以前面板双户空单真的多
就看他们没有啦
但是拉上来的话
可能也会有嘎空的行情
对 好 所以如果需要今天节目
所有的图卡资料的话
欢迎订阅一下我们赵华
艾伦所有的YouTube频道
我们每一集都会把这些图卡
免费放在首页
有一个贴文栏
点进去就可以做下载
慢慢的研读
因为等一下
我们有两位大来宾
一个要讲产业
一个要讲量价关系
都非常值得听
就是因为现在是一个
关键转折点
那我们来期待一下吧
欢迎回来赵花
我跟你说
我跟你讲
我们节目超级有诚意的
因为呢
现在不是都在讲成交量低吗
没错
结果我们要增加来宾的人数
嘿嘿
多一点人来喊信心喊话
因为我们两个人讲可能不够了
所以我们要让大家知道
像现在比较沉浅
或者是有一些关卡卡在这边的时候
往往酝酿的叫做什么呢
什么
黎明前的黑暗将来就会是大展光明
哦
突然好真相
好正能量
好 突然
做一下效果
我們先來歡迎今天大來賓有兩位
第一位呢
久久還很久沒有來了
但是每次觀眾看到她來
都非常開心的
就是統一頭褲的總經理
PCB女王廖婉婷
歡迎婉婷
嗨 趙華愛惹
我突然卡住 太久沒來了
太久沒來了
好 今天婉婷來
要先幫我們從產業面上
打雞血啦
因為婉婷前陣子去看了半導體戰
所以呢对于第四季到明年
今天我们不讲PCB
今天反而是要讲
看完半导体展之后
你有个感想
就是大封测时代要来临了
对
我们很需要你的加持
因为说实话
今年封测股的涨势
其实是没有其他的AI股来得多
然后一直在期待业绩赶快成长
那为什么看完半导体展之后
会觉得大封测时代要来临
另外当然是最近大家比较担心的
AI真的有降速降規的問題嗎
好 就是週末的時候
三大巨頭Athropeak開始講
他的員工就離職
然後就說再不管的話
AI會完蛋
然後他有可能在未來的某一天
殺死全人類
有10%的機率
10%還滿高的
對 然後所以Athropeak就開始講
就呼籲說要放慢發展的速度
好 但是這個是指的是AI的模型
它並不是表示AI的基建
其實模型跟基建是兩件事
而且模型它指的是非常前沿的
就是還在可能沙盒裡面測試的
並不是現在已經開始開賣的模型
那現在開賣的這些大圓模型
才是會跟基建比較直接的相關
所以我不會認為說
這個時間點AI的基建會放緩
只要AI基建沒有放緩
台灣的賣產值的業績
就會繼續的水漲船高
是
對 所以我覺得這個恐慌有
因為大家搞不清楚
所以需要我們來跟大家說清楚
好 那大家的信心回來了之後
這件事情立空就會結束
然後當然就是因為大家害怕
所以股市包括半導體費半就跌了
然後所以川普跟華人勳
就通上了電話
然後告訴大家說
才不會咧
AI算力本來就是未來的國力還有新石油
所以怎麼可能會停止
然後所以末日論就是一個騙局
對 所以大佬就跟你講說
不要太擔心
好 一個是美國的BOSS
一個是AI央行BOSS
沒錯
這個Enthropic跟OpenAI
回答的都是大股東
所以黃仁勳講話他們應該要聽一下吧對 是對 所以基本上我們認為不太會停手對 所以大家不用那麼恐慌是可是你這個信心需要被安撫一下
好
但是呢
我們這邊要信心安撫
除了大佬的喊話
其實前一陣子的半導體戰
展前轟轟烈烈
就展後大家安安靜靜
但是其實婉婷去看完之後
心裡是激動的
對 我是覺得很棒的
那我覺得
我剛剛在趙華來介紹的時候
我突然想到一個點
就是为什么今年风测股比较弱
因为今年是涨价年
今年是供需失衡的涨价年
对
但是今天的发展是它是盖房子
它房子现在里面越堆越多
越盖越大
但是呢
风测它并没有走向涨价这件事情
它在盖房子
可是它没有
这个房子没有在涨价
所以今年的投资主轴
它跑去了供需失衡的涨价股
导致这种盖房子越盖越大
但是加量不加价的
看起來股價比較弱
可是明年我認為
我自己會認為說
供需失衡這件事情會慢慢淡化
所以漲價的族群
它的光環可能會退掉
它也許不會跌
因為AI還在發展
他們的公司的企業貨利還會在增長
可是價格驅動力會不見
好那所以回來
大家就會看規格升級這個議題
好那規格升級這個議題
就是晶片現在
因為你功能要越來越多
你2.5D封装变3D封装
3.5D封装
那这个就是有点像之前
就是机体跟主晶片放在一起
就COAS
然后未来就是COOP或CPU
你的OE光引擎会进来
然后再共同封装
所以它就会从2.5D往3.5D走
好 然后所以当你要放
越来越多东西的时候
你的房子就要越盖越大
你才住得下这么多的人
好 所以你封装
就叫做盖房子把房子盖起来
封装的厂商订单就会
越来越多
好然后
可是今年比较辛苦的
就是我们之前还提到
日月光晶元店
因为它的资本支出先投
它要盖房子
它必须要有产能
它先投了
折旧出来
结果业绩还不够
然后就导致获利成长性不够强
那跟这个报价类股PK就输了
所以封测厂商经营获利的YY
强度不够
大家就不爱
可是明年
我已经投完了
我接下來要開始創造收入
創造獲利
所以明言的重點就會再封測
是
對 那我在半導體展看到
就是好多複雜的晶片
然後廠商在告訴你說
我在這裡面扮演什麼樣的角色
那像這個就是日月光展的
這個就是一個CPL的模型
然後這個就是所謂的
ESIC或GPU
然後這就是記憶體堆疊
這個就是所謂的2.5D封裝
然後在旁邊這個放的就是OE引擎
然後這樣一大顆
就是一個非常大的晶片
以前晶片只有這樣一顆
現在晶片這麼大顆
對 所以這個就是我當初在講
為什麼載板用量會增加的關鍵
好 然後這個也是
其實就是堆疊式封章
所以你就會知道說
要這樣封裝
除了先進製程很強
然後再來就是大晶片
我封裝 大晶片
對 大晶片架構
所以我把它濃縮叫大封測
喔 好 大晶片
對 晶片越來越大
然後封裝的需求才能消耗
然後測試時間要變長
所以大封測
然後相關的材料設備股都會收回
好 然後所以我在現場
我也看到也有封測
還有測試的探針卡
還有這個測試底座
所以我們從就是ProCart 探針卡
然後到這個測試機座的引威
然後到這個SLT
還有這個Final Test
就是晶片測試
好 這些就是過去我們講引威旺系
好 然後跟這個老化測試
就是一樣就是金測
好 這些就是測試設備
然後呢 晶圓測試的部分
就要在COAS
它就會是台積電跟日月光做
然後晶片測試的話
就是那個晶圓電
好 所以日月光晶圓電
然後跟我們剛剛講的
晶測 隱微 望系
都會是有關係 跟晶片有關
然後另外就是光的部分
因為光OE引擎要進來
然後所以現在設備廠商
積極的在做這個光晶片的測試
那它總共有四個步驟
然後第二個步驟
跟第三個步驟最難做
所以這個有點卡關
讓OE引擎稍微比較慢的原因
可是就是因為卡關
所以它是更重要的
對 所以我這邊就幫大家整理了一下
今年跟明年的獲利
然後就可以看到很明顯的
就是有一些獲利的成長性很強
對 然後題材性在這邊
好 然後本益比的部分
其實為什麼今年不漲
因為今年其實初
大家就知道大晶片概念
所以股價漲超多
去年底到今年漲很多
所以PE本來拉太高
但是因為最近休息了
所以反而你現在往
時間點多過了一年之後
你會發現它P掉下來了
對 然後明後年大風測
獲利成長性夠高
P又沒有很高的時候
我覺得這個族群就會是
今年底往明年
很好的佈局的產業
好 因為像尹薇曾經是萬元股
沒錯
結果現在已經掉到6000塊了
雖然是高價股
但回檔幅度非常深
事實上如果明年能夠呼應它
可能有高達這個
70幾%的年增率的話
它搞不好又可以
重新回到一個成長的軌道上
是這樣看
日月光跟晶圓店就是相对比较
牛皮 比较委屈的
可是因为PE很低
对
对 所以非常安全
好 所以要成长有成长
要安全有安全
好 那我们就来看一下
日月光真的横盘整理
晶圓店也很多人就是投诉说
到底为什么
他们资本支出已经创下
令年的新高
怎么还没有涨这样子
对 因为它
其实去年涨非常多
但是今年就受到
它的资本支出
所以导致折就增加太多了
可是这些折旧对明年就是好事
因为我的业绩就可以开始创造收入
是 好
所以这个是安全组
对 就是风色双雄
这个就是活泼组
但是潜力无穷
对 那像接拥振
拥振就长停
对 因为它就是有
透过那个风格
然后拿到有机会切进联发科
然后因为联发科
现在就是大家很关注
它Google订单
所以就会觉得
它未来成长性会有机会
然后另外旺系的部分的话
其实大家期待很高
可是因为它最近那个
之前的座堂会讲
第三季的展望
稍微比较保守
所以股价就相对比较弱
可是9月如果出来
优于公司奖
大家就会认为说
公司可能是过度保守
那未来的期待还是很高的时候
可能反而股价
就会在那个时间点动
好 就是很谢谢婉妮
跟我们分享了
看完半导体战以后
迎接所谓的大风测试
大家谢谢你
好 谢谢
好 欢迎回来赵华
阿倫说
我们赶快来欢迎第二位来宾
刚刚已经讲了产业面
是
接下来就要看所谓的量价关系了
非常重要 运线没量
运线没量
没关系
朱老师来就有量
下来欢迎他
就是我们的朱家宏老师
K仙之神
大家好
跟我们太熟了
对
对 常常碰面
因为最近朱老师有帮盘下了一个注解
好事总是多磨
因为盘好磨
沒錯 沒錯
最近盤大家覺得很難做
但是什麼事情都有這個
好事多磨嘛
那就後面有好事
所以現在在磨磨你
但是不管我們在這個中間很難做
但是你一定會有收穫的
那投資也是一樣
我們投資也是有賺有賠
但是你在賺賠的中間
你也會有很多寶貴的經驗
然後奠定你日後成功
所以你經過一段磨練
那以後大機會來
那就是你的
因為大家可能被前一陣子
那種大的波動養壞胃口了
其實股市的盤整是常態
對
所以從盤整中找機會
是更重要的
沒錯
主要是最近我們一直在講
就是量的問題
沒錯
因為好的時候有到1兆
就1.8兆
對
現在的話五六千億
差這麼多
所以量價關係要教我們
来看股价的推背图
其实在股市里面
你如果看懂量价关系
你都知道它后面的变化
但是一般人
为什么不太容易分辨
就是你把量价关系
跟趋势分开来了
你只看量
实际上我们看量价关系
要跟趋势结合
你是在看多头空头
还是现在在盘整
盘整里面也会有量
有的时候有量说
有时候有量真
好 像多头趋势
这边有讲多头起涨
量增就一漲
那我们大部分都做多嘛
所以如果你是在起涨
也就是我们讲到回后埋上涨
盘整突破
这都是第一根嘛
如果第一根有量的话
那这个我们一般来说
它就容易涨
也叫做供给量
这个量叫供给量
多头行进中的话
量增就会续涨
对 那如果一样嘛
它行进的意思就是
第二天第三天
第二天第三天连续在放量
那当然它就是
繼續再供期
那如果多頭遇到高檔量
真的就不好了
那高檔我們就講過三天以上
第三天 第四天
這個地方如果
繼續的放大量的話
那你就要小心了
因為在高檔有量
這個容易被人家出貨
因為有量說他們沒辦法出貨
但量一大就容易出貨
那怎麼觀察呢
就是如果它有大量
第二天股價不漲了
或者當天
當天放了大量
结果开高走低 股价下跌
那这时候大概出货的
几率就非常高
你要小心
那同样的一样
上涨到高档预压了
所以量增也是同样是
出货的概念了
因为你预压
本来就是有人在解套
到了这些位置
你就要注意
这个地方可能是出货
那换句话讲
第一个我们做多
不会买在高档
也不会买在压力
可是你手上有多单
这时候你要准备停利
要停利
好 最后当然是刚刚讲到
这些可能都造成回档
可是回档只要量开始缩了
那就代表卖压减少了
对 因为多头回档
在高档爆量就是该出的就出了
或解套的有卖掉了
那你这时候就要看回来
如果回来量缩掉
这个量缩反而好
表示卖压减轻
也没有很大的继续在杀你
那如果量缩的话
碰到支撑的就容易停住了
因为我们支撑就是一个
對抗下跌
那你下跌量少
我支撐夠強
我自然就會把它抵住
那點住的時候
我們就會看到
它會不會又出現
第一個量增上漲
對不對
因為你量縮
然後我把你撐住
你再出來一個量增的上漲
那它又開始攻下面一波
好一個循環
好這在多頭裡面
大概你的位置都有了
多頭上漲
高檔 預壓 回檔
预支撑
大概你把这些量放上去
你做多大概可以研判
那在空头里面就不一样了
空头里面各位就不要看错了
比如说空头起跌
就低跟下跌
低跟下跌如果有大量
那就不但会跌还容易急跌
可能连续就杀下去了
所以在空头的起跌这一方
是我们做空
那做空有量就变好了
它会大跌
所以就可以继续空调这样
那行径如果量缩
大家容易误会
这跟刚才不一样
刚才说下跌量缩好
对不对
这边讲的
可是空头下跌量缩还会继续跌
因为各位有一个观念
我空头下跌是不是要涨的话
要有人来买
要有人接
对
那如果你是量缩
表示你不要乱接
很多人都看价钱去接股票
哇 跌三天了
我在摸底
那結果它沒有量
那我們一般閃會去摸
你摸不出來的
一定要有別人來大量所以量說會續跌那空投低檔就是跌了兩三天也就是這個的相反跌了兩三天 量放大了
它反而容易止住
就是有點底部放大量
對 底部放量 然後有人來買了
這個時候容易反彈
容易反彈我們要確認
那就是第二天
我如果底部放量
第二天不跌了
或者下銀線 或者變
這個地方大概就容易反彈
那容易反弹对我们来讲
因为我们做多嘛
空头你不能做多
反弹不能做多
所以这是给你空单要回补的
如果你是做空单在低档
也看到大量
那你就准备回补了
要回补了
那如果你下跌遇到了支撑
空头我们现在都在讲空头
不是多头遇到支撑
空头如果遇到支撑
比如说你跌跌跌到半年线
那这个地方如果出现
有量大它一样也容易反弹
这个地方有支撑嘛
就有支撑的力量出现
那另外空头上涨
那叫反弹喔
所以这个都要搞
空头反弹
如果量缩它就容易结束了
也就是说我们反弹无量
反弹无力
反弹无量就准备做空
准备也许它谈不动
明天就跌了
那明天一跌又回来这里了
又变起跌了
我们多空都有讲喔
对
所以多空不但有降
而且多空的每個位置
你都可以去配合再看一下
你今天看到的炸量
是多頭的這裡
還是空頭的這裡
那我相信你對這個量
就能夠分析了
那還有一個盤整
大家比較忽略盤整
那盤整裡面有兩種情形
在多頭的盤整
如果這個多頭要攻的話
大概量都會縮
在盤整裡面不太會有量
那在什麼時候才有量
就是盤整的突破
也就是我們多頭的起漲
盤整的突破
那這時候就會有量
另外一個就是盤整放量
在多頭也會盤整裡面放量
那這要小心 要看位置
如果你這個盤整在第三波末升段
那有可能會做頭
所以不能跌破
如果盤整放量的跌破
那個量就是阻力出貨
就阻力出貨
那空頭如果是跌到低檔
空頭一直跌 跌到低檔
那也在盘整
这个地方如果放量的话
那就是我们刚刚讲
空头放量就会反弹
那这个地方放量盘整
如果是突破它就转多了
那这个量就叫
我们就叫做进货量
主力在这边进货
所以你如果是盘整
也是看多头的盘整
还是空头的盘整
还是多头底部的盘整
还是空头底部的盘整
还是多头高档的盘整
你加上量价
最後看它是突破還是跌破
你大概也知道
這個成交量代表什麼意思
是 我們現在的台股位置
算是多頭高檔的盤整嗎
對 對
因為現在跌破前提
所以是盤整
那現在盤整量縮
對 好不好
沒有 原來是好事
我們講了那麼大一篇
現在是好事
對啊 對啊
所以我們現在大盤
趨勢改了嘛
可是量縮
就等著量增
等著大量來
把這個盤整突破
它就會有走另外一波
我們每次卡在你們兩個中間
你們兩個都了然於胸
然後我就在旁邊很吃驚這樣子
對
不會 那你就代表觀眾
今天不可以考試囉
今天沒有時間考試
我們就看看範益就知道了
有些股票前面都走過了
但是你當時可能不知道量價的關係
那现在知道你可以回头看一下
好
你就会发现真的有道理
你看这一波一路下跌对不对
量缩这边没有量
还会跌
你不要有个量缩你随便就去减
你减了它还会跌
那什么时候才不会跌这年
下跌低档低档大量
它就容易停了
那容易停还要看第二天
第二天涨停板
那这一涨停板当然没有量
这个没话讲因为
开盘就涨停了
那涨停板本身也代表很多的
背后的意义
这个也是阻力开的
然后第二天就看到了有量了
开始连续放量
所以这个叫大量反弹
是
那反弹我们都好高兴
你可能去追高什么
不要忘了这才高档
反弹在高档不要随放
放量
你如果放量大
它就容易回来
回来
好那这一回来
这个大量就变成压力了
所以你在這個地方遇到壓力的大量
千萬不要追好
對 你在壓力的大量
你一去追它就回來了
所以現在假設以這檔環保安店來講
因為高檔爆量 高檔爆量
而且跌破了
那就是我們講盤整有量
跌破了 所以它變空頭了
所以現在也一樣
就算你連漲三天你都不能買
因為這個是阻力
我們也不一定是主力
在這個地方就有大量的賣壓在這
那這也有可能上次跌
上次大跌很多人
你看最高點是不是大量
所以那邊有被套牢
所以你在這個急速反彈的時候
這裡就有一些賣壓在這裡
這樣子我們去觀察
把趨勢看好 現在是空投
所以空投如果反彈沒量
它不會上的
它不會上去的
剛剛那個表各位回去看一下
空投反弹煤量是要做空的
是 就弹不动了
再下来要做空
所以这样子大家就可以配合上来
好 金居
好 那金居也一样
涨到了700多块
创历史高点
然后这里面出了两个大量
那这两个大量如果跌破
这个是空投嘛 对不对
反弹又下来
那这个就是我们刚刚讲的
多头的高档
金居讲到700多是高高在上
那这里的大量盘整
不可以跌破
那跌破是出貨
所以這是主力在出貨
主力出掉
那出掉了
空頭下跌量是縮的
這沒有量
那可是還會跌
對啊 一路跌
那什麼時候你才會覺得有機會
就是沙沙沙出現大量
那大量第二天也是漲停板
然後開始反彈
從這個反彈
才會打出底底高
然後變成多頭
那多頭這裡有大量
為什麼
因为这里有压
这里有个季线
季线压在上面
所以在这里有了大量
可是这个大量
它已经变成一个多头架构
现在已经你的量价
要换成多头的那一块了
前面这是空头这一块
现在变成多头来看量
好 那我们现在的趋势
我们的经济在盘整
很清楚嘛 头头低
但有没有破底 还没有
所以它是一个盘整
那在多头里面
這已經是多頭的盤整
那多頭盤整理有大量
這你有大量
所以這個盤整不可以跌破
那跌破就是這個多又轉空
那如果突破呢
那突破就很好了
突破多頭盤整
如果大量突破
他就要再回去攻那個七八
七五八
要再回去攻七五八
所以這你就變成量價很關係的位置
你是往上突了還是往下跌破
因為你跌破這裡有大量被套牢
那這個有可能短期
因為我們在低檔是不是有大量
那可能短期這些進貨的
在這裡你就先走掉了
所以這個後面大家要密切去看一下
好 那我們就來檢驗一下
最近的熱門題材股
最近有幾支股票
郁星光回檔減少停辦
郁星光非常強
可是我們有沒有看到
它這裡有個大量
這邊 對
這在高檔
所以它会整理会休息
那休息以后
它再冲出去的时候没有量
那没有量就容易回来
我们讲上涨要有量
所以其实上它这一根
这根回后买上涨盘整突破
它没有量
所以它很容易回来
那回来以后
它现在又开始放量
下跌的时候有量
这有量
但是它碰到支撑了
那这个应该是今天
今天所长听
对
那今天就是遇到支撑
然后出现
但今天有一个弱点就是没有量
因为它锁住了
那怎么办
锁住了
因为太好了
好 没关系
没有量就看明天
因为我们量是可以延续看
如果我起涨第一天量不够
就要看后面来补量
因为你要攻上面高点
就可以补量
第一个要确认趋势
它以现在来讲趋势并不好
它是盘整
因为它把这个低点跌破了
对啊
它前面这个低点跌破了
所以它是过高破低嘛
那过高破低
你的压力就在1140
那你1140的压力
你这边的量不太够
所以要持续放量去过这个1140
它才会多头延续
那这支股票是底部
滑金因为最近资安很热
因为这个很明确啦
因为它多头确认了嘛
那1234所以在高档
然後又再壓力
對不對
所以它是多頭高檔
預壓的爆量
所以明後天不能跌
只能漲不能跌
因為你有大量
我這個量超級大
對 漲的話就是換手成功
那跌的話就是
預壓爆量
這個短線獲利
短線獲利一層兩層
有可能這邊賣壓就出來
所以如果這支手上有多單的
你已經預壓爆量了
所以要注意
股價只能漲不能跌
明天要收黑K
大家要回檔
那你就可以短線獲利一趟
就可以獲利一趟
那回檔再看嘛 量縮嘛
那就就是良性的價量配合
那這個我們都可以去追蹤
好 最後看一下被動元件的
和升堂
和升堂跟我們剛才講的
價量關係一樣
這邊有大量做反彈
反彈的最高點
這裡要連續三天大量
這三天都大量
那大量這裡就產生了壓力
所以一樣你把這個壓力畫一條線
OK
那如果在
因為為什麼這邊還會整理一下
因為這時候季線還沒有做好
月線還在下面
那現在整理大家也發現
月線已經開始要過季線
對
過季線了
那現在只欠一個東風
因為這裡全部都有大量
對不對
那如果這個紅K一過來
那這個大量就是底部量
它就是空投低檔盤整的大量
那這個大量突破
那當然一定是供那個1045
因為這個量絕對夠去供這個地方
那那個是高檔的量
然後被跌破了
所以那邊有人被套牢
現在是低檔盤整的量
那突破它就去挑戰內民
那這樣大家可以去追蹤一下
紫倩东风你喊一下啊
好 东风
东风快喊
会啦 因为大盘如果整理好
大盘转强
自然有资金的人
一定都是看这种底部打底的股票
那如果你又突破
那个资金就会进来了
好 今天非常谢谢朱老师
其实量价关系很值得研究
就让大家可能觉得最近闷盘
还有人说最近就是交易的垃圾时间
可是其实呼应到盘面的局势是好的
因為盤整量所等突破
一旦突破後面真的就是很值得期待
所以你看懂了你就很幽呆的等
很幽呆
你不會擔心
可以不要上班嗎